[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas Estados Unidos ha
advertido de graves consecuencias
económicas a Rusia si se materializan
los temores de una invasión de tropas
rusas en Ucrania y es que quien asegura
que Moscú mantiene amasados a miles de
soldados cerca de su frontera sin
embargo el kremlin niega cualquier
intención bélica la situación sigue
siendo particularmente tensa en la
región del Don Bass al este de Ucrania
donde los combates persisten el
siguiente es un reportaje de nuestros
corresponsales
la fábrica de Carbón de abdica mantuvo a
flote la ciudad ucraniana de la línea
del frente durante toda la guerra aquí
prefieren no hablar del conflicto
sin comentarios
intento no ver las noticias la vida ya
es bastante dura
sin embargo el sur de la ciudad está
devastado por los combates
el ejército ucraniano mantiene sus
posiciones en las fábricas en ruinas
aquí los intercambios de fuego son casi
diarios el enemigo estaba menos de 100
metros pues
no tiene ningún seguimiento pueden
dispararle a cualquier cosa en cualquier
momento para este oficial la cuestión de
una invasión de Ucrania por parte de
Rusia es obsoleta
territorio Rusia ya está en territorio y
ucraniano necesitamos más pruebas que
cuando capturamos a un prisionero de
guerra y tiene pasaporte ruso
sin embargo estos soldados no esperan
una escalada mayor
siguen diciendo que va a haber un ataque
que los rusos están acumulando sus
fuerzas por eso no lo creo sufrirían
demasiadas pérdidas
la niña del frente en el don vas no se
ha movido significativamente en casi
siete años pero la situación sigue
siendo inestable hasta que Rusia acepte
la orientación Pro occidental de Ucrania
y esta acepte la ocupación de parte de
su territorio por las fuerzas del
kremlin
a 5 kilómetros de la línea del frente
New York es una ciudad ucraniana
y los miembros de este centro
comunitario al igual que los
estadounidenses Están preocupados por la
concentración de tropas rusas en la
frontera
con lo que está sucediendo es difícil
escuchar que podría ser aún peor siete
años de guerra ya son suficientemente
duros
y ahora somos conscientes de que durará
mucho tiempo
estaremos así el resto de nuestras vidas
en esta ciudad los últimos atentados
contra zonas habitadas se fueron en 2019
del Mar Caribe al mar del Norte siempre
Buscando una mejor vida y huyendo de la
crisis Así ha crecido poco a poco la
comunidad Venezolana en Aberdeen Escocia
una ciudad que es conocida como la
capital petrolera de Europa la historia
de la diáspora venezolana a esa ciudad
es un reflejo de la muy difícil
situación que ha tenido que atravesar
ese país latinoamericano en los últimos
años y este es un reportaje de Luisa
Pulido y David López
en 2007 isaas con su bizarreta llegó a
verdines Escocia a casi 8.000 kilómetros
de Caracas Venezuela para trabajar en la
prospera Industria petrolera Del Reino
Unido ella como más de 20.000 expertos
de la estatal petrolera pdvsa fueron
despedidos en 2003 por oponerse al
gobierno de Hugo Chávez y se dispersaron
por el mundo para no perder sus carreras
profesionales el venezolano siempre es
bienvenido porque porque traemos una
vamos a decir no solamente el
conocimiento que lo aprendemos
obviamente pues en la universidad es que
eran muy buenas sino también traemos una
cultura de trabajo que ellos la aprecian
porque nosotros no tenemos miedo a nada
Diego mejías también llegó persiguiendo
un trabajo en la industria petrolera
pero ahora se desenvuelve en otros
oficios Bueno yo soy sexy Player
handyman y entonces todo lo que se
necesita en las casas este repararlo
bueno la gente me llama y y lo voy
reparando bueno el reconocimiento de la
crisis social en Venezuela ha sido el
detonante para el aumento de la
migración aberdín a la que llegaron
inicialmente expertos en petróleo pero
desde 2013 comenzaron a llegar
venezolanos con distintas profesiones
como segundo y su esposa Ana ambos
arquitectos propietarios de latin way el
único restaurante suramericano en la
ciudad Hemos llegado
con ganas de compartir nuestra cultura y
nuestra y nuestra gastronomía Carlos fue
uno de los primeros latinos en aterrizar
en esta ciudad hoy celebra que poco a
poco la cultura venezolana se va a
expandiendo en el 2006 seríamos unas
ocho o diez familias venezolanos
llegar de Venezuela a un país tan frío
como este y con los días tan cortos el
cambio fue muy brusco no hay cifras
oficiales de Cuántos venezolanos viven
hoy en Aberdeen la mayoría aprovechó su
herencia europea para establecerse en
esta fría esquina del mundo que les ha
ofrecido las oportunidades que perdieron
en su país
gracias A las pruebas de VIH y a los
tratamientos sin costo Irán ha dado
grandes pasos para detener la
propagación del SIDA y Teherán también
aprobó una ley para combatir la
discriminación de los pacientes que
padecen esta enfermedad sin embargo
organizaciones no gubernamentales han
expresado preocupación Porque tanto en
la educación nacional como en los medios
de comunicación se siguen quedando atrás
en este tema y esto sobre todo tras la
llegada al poder del ultraconservador
Ibrahim Racing informe de nuestros
reporteros en Irán
quería alertar a otros iraníes sobre la
enfermedad que sin saber se había
propagado en su cuerpo sabiéndose
protegido por ley decidió aparecer en
televisión para hablar sobre el virus
del VIH su valentía tuvo un costo
quería educar a mi familia y vecinos y
después de eso mi barbero se excusó por
no atenderme el comportamiento de la
mayoría cambió pague el precio por
preocuparme por otros
Irán registró 59 mil casos de VIH en
2020 cerca de 20.000 resultaron en
muerte las pruebas y los tratamientos
para todos son gratuitos Pero según los
expertos Muchos pacientes los rechazan
por miedo a la exclusión social raja
mortasabi es activista en la lucha
contra el sida mucha gente tiene temor
de entrar al centro temen a las miradas
y a las acusaciones de los demás los
bautizados como autobuses del sida como
este han viajado por los caminos de Irán
en años recientes desarrollando campañas
de toma de conciencia y haciendo
consultas exámenes y pruebas gratis pero
el programa terminó el año pasado Sin
ninguna explicación oficial y nuevas
leyes impiden la distribución gratuita
de condones un Claro retroceso en la
campaña de Irán contra el sida
hay gente que no se da cuenta de que
negar la existencia de la enfermedad
eleva su propagación ellos se niegan a
hablar al respecto en público Son ellos
los que evitan que se desarrollen estos
programas el Ministerio de iraní de
salud estima que hay 20.000 casos no
registrados de sida y la cifra de
mujeres infectadas ha crecido de 19 a
32%.
la empresa italiana Ferrero fabricante
de la crema de untar nutella se ha
planteado un nuevo objetivo es el de
aumentar en un 30% la producción de
avellanas italianas esto con el objetivo
de depender menos de Turquía que es el
principal proveedor a nivel mundial sin
embargo la idea no ha sido Del agrado de
muchos habitantes ni de asociaciones
medioambientales como lo explican
nuestros corresponsales Natalia Mendoza
lorenza pensa Luis malnoa y han donadini
desde el cielo se ven por todos lados
avellanos hasta donde alcanza la vista
en esta provincia a unos 60 kilómetros
al norte de Roma el 90% de la superficie
arbórea está dedicada al cultivo de
avellanas
Romeo es un emprendedor agrícola antes
en sus terrenos crecían los cereales
pero como muchos en la zona ha decidido
cambiarse a las avellanas mucho más
rentables
la ventaja del cultivo de avellanas es
que no necesita de mucha mano de obra y
no tenemos problemas para venderlas
contrario a lo que pasa con las frutas y
las legumbres que vendemos directamente
al consumidor las avellanas las vendemos
a la industria y eso tiene ventajas las
ventajas son tener un cliente como la
empresa Ferrero y el productor de la
nutella encargada de un programa que
compra al menos el 75% de la cosecha
anual de avellanas algo atractivo para
las más importantes cooperativas y
productores y el proyecto noche a la
Italia el programa de Ferrero Busca
darle la tranquilidad al productor para
que tenga la certeza de que su producto
será comprado y nos permite vender al
mejor precio
sin embargo el monocultivo de avellanas
con alto consumo de agua está acusado de
perjudicar El sistema local es una
cultura intensiva que es un cultivo
intensivo que emplea pesticidas y
fertilizantes sustancias químicas que se
vierten en El aguante arriba no Y
obviamente eso favorece el desarrollo de
algunas algas tóxicas que genera un
cóctel de sustancias tóxicas
cancerígenas
la agencia regional para la protección
del medio ambiente ha confirmado la
toxicidad del agua del Lago que alimenta
los acueductos de como unas cercanas sus
habitantes están divididos entre la
preocupación y la resignación la cual el
agua no es potable nos dicen que a
priori podemos cocinar con ella pero
tengo dos niños pequeños prefiero no
arriesgar entonces compró toda mi agua
en botella Italia tiene previsto
aumentar la superficie de cultivos de
avellana en los próximos años para
llegar a las 90000 hectáreas de aquí a
la lira turca sigue debilitándose esta
moneda ha perdido el 40% de su valor
frente al Dólar tan solo en lo corrido
de 2021 gran parte de ello después de
que el presidente reyerta y perduan
asegurará que mantendrá su política de
bajos rangos de interés y mientras la
situación financiera de los turcos va de
mal en peor sus vecinos búlgaros y
griegos aprovechan la volatilidad del
tipo de cambio informe de nuestros
reporteros en Turquía
se ha convertido en una escena familiar
cada vez que la lira turca baja los
vehículos griegos y búlgaros se dirigen
a la frontera en edirne entrasia
Oriental Este mercado es un destino
apreciado por quien los vendedores
llaman consum vecino esta familia vino
de Bulgaria
aquí es mucho más barato que en Bulgaria
cuatro veces más baratos compramos ropa
llenamos el depósito y volvemos a
Bulgaria
otros en cambio se desplazan durante
horas desde Grecia
los salarios no son muy altos en Grecia
entonces aquí para nosotros es una buena
oportunidad
9 liras hoy 14 Así que es mucho mejor
para nosotros
con la caída de la lira los precios
suben y el poder adquisitivo Turco se
reduce los clientes turcos especialmente
estos dos últimos meses ya no pueden
permitirse comprar todo se ha vuelto
demasiado caro para ellos por ejemplo
con el salario mínimo 3000 liras apenas
podemos comprar lo suficiente para comer
a medida que la crisis económica se
agrava la respuesta del gobierno a veces
resulta contradictoria por un lado el
presidente dice que es víctima de un
complete internacional contra las
finanzas del país por otro espera
convencer a la opinión pública de que la
situación está bajo control que todo
forma parte de un plan a largo plazo
para impulsar la producción el empleo y
el crecimiento
Gracias por acompañarnos en una nueva
emisión de corresponsales nos damos cita
en el 2022 siga con más información en
francés 24 y France 24.com